he's on a list he's the low line fruit
right now so we should Circle back on
this and whether it's six months or a
year I have a feeling Howard Stern is
going to be on the chopping block this
is why he's going so extreme in the
other direction yeah exactly he's so you
got a treadmill right and it's speeding
up and people are being flung off the
right side of it and Howard Stern is
running as fast as he can because he's
on that edge and he's got to just try an
inch as much again it's going to be
really difficult for him but I mean I
got I gotta be honest he would be better
off if he just stayed himself yeah if he
totally just went the shut up you losers
and just stayed himself he'd be doing
way better he doesn't have to support
Trump he doesn't have to hate vaccines
he just needs to stop being a whiny
little loser who's like just bending the
knee and doing whatever he's told but
whatever man hey he can do he can do
whatever he wants uh he has I wonder if
he has any respect from anyone I'll I'll
I'll I'll I'll add this
he's saying whatever Boomers he thinks
whatever he thinks Boomers want to hear